now here I am in my brand new bigquery
studio a unified workbench for all our
data services I open a notebook from
here to do an analysis we're going to
build a marketing campaign here
and right there I am in my bigquery
notebook attached my data set to the
notebook and I'm generating code with
the help of duet AI
to segment my customers into 10
different segments and to plot them and
I generate this code using natural
language
and I have the code that is clustering
using k-means clusters into 10 different
clusters it's also trying to plot that
information for us now you see here in
green we have our most frequent orders
and then in Orange we have got customers
who do not order with us and haven't
ordered with us in a long time
now this function right here is the cool
part we this is bigquery and Vortex AI
integration and now you can directly
connect to Palm to our lodge language
model do some prompt engineering and
generate these emails and there we have
all of our emails generated using the
power of generative Ai and bigquery
right here